KARMEL ALLISON: Hi and
welcome to Coding TensorFlow.
I'm Karmel Allison, and
I'm here to guide you
through a scenario using
TensorFlow's high-level APIs.
This video is the
third and final part
of a three-part series.
In the first video,
we looked at data
and how to prepare your
data for machine learning.
We then moved on to optimizing
your data for machine learning
with TensorFlow
and keras including
building a simple model.
And here's the model we defined.
We will start with a simple
sequential model, which
strings together
the modular keras
layers, hooking
the output of each
into the input of the next.
Our first layer will
do all of the data
transformations
we just discussed,
and then we go through some
standard densely connected
layers.
Our final layer here will
output the class predictions
for each of the four
wilderness areas
that we are interested in.
Notice here that we are just
establishing the architecture
of our model, and
we still haven't yet
hooked it up to any data.
Once we have the layer
architecture established,
we can compile the model,
which adds the optimizer, loss,
and metrics we
are interested in.
TensorFlow provides a number
of optimizers and lost choices,
which we could explore
if we wanted to.
And finally the
rubber meets the road.
We pass our data set into
our model, and we train.
Now in a real world situation
with large data sets,
we would likely want to
leverage hardware accelerators
like GPUs or TPUs.
And we may even want
to distribute training
across multiple GPUs or nodes.
You can find out more about
using distribution strategies
for this in the links included
in the description below.
So for now I will just point
out that the same code will
work in the distributed
settings and when
eager execution is disabled.
For now, we will just
assume that we will wait
for this to finish training.
Once it's done training,
you can test it.
And while that's
pretty straightforward,
we first need to load
in our validation data.
It's important here that we use
the same processing procedure
for our test data that we
did for our training data.
So maybe we'll define a function
that we can use in both cases
to ensure repeatability.
We call the evaluate
method of our model
with the validation data, which
returns the loss and accuracy
that we get on our test data.
Note here that because
we took care of our data
transformations using
feature columns,
we know that the transformation
of our input validation data
will happen in the same way
as it did for our training
data, which is critical to
ensuring repeatable results.
So now we validated our
model on independent
held out data that was processed
in the same way as our training
data.
And we can pretend
for a minute that we
are happy with the
results, and we
are ready to deploy this model.
There is a lot of
tooling that is required
for real world deployment, which
the library TFX makes possible.
I put a link to this in
the description below.
TensorFlow provides
a model saving format
that works with the suite
of TensorFlow products,
including TensorFlow
Serving and TensorFlow.js.
The TensorFlow saved model
includes a checkpoint with all
of the weights and variables,
and it also includes the graph
that we built for training,
evaluating, and predicting.
Keras now natively
exports to TensorFlow
saved model format for serving.
This saved model is a fully
contained serialization
of your model, so you can
load it back into Python later
if you want to retrain
or reuse your model.
And now we've gone through
all of the critical stages
to build a model for
our data in TensorFlow.
And maybe we're done.
It could be that this is the
perfect model, and we're happy.
But then we'd all have
to go and find new jobs,
so let's assume that we
want to improve the accuracy
of the model we have built.
There are lots of places we
might decide to make changes.
We could go and
collect more data.
We could change the way we
process and parse the data.
We could change the
model architecture,
add or remove layers.
We could change the
optimizer or the loss.
We could try different
hyper parameters and so on.
What I will show
you today is how
to use the same data
and features to try out
one of TensorFlow's
canned estimators, which
are built in
implementations of some more
complex models including
those that don't fit nicely
into a layer-based architecture.
So what if we wanted
to shake things
up and try a different model?
To rewind, this is
the model we had,
a densely connected
neural network.
Let's try changing it.
Here we are using the
same feature columns,
but we're configuring one of the
TensorFlow canned estimators.
We are using the DNN
linear combined classifier,
which is also known as
the wide and deep model.
And that gives us
an architecture
that looks something
like this, allowing
us to trivially leverage
all the research that
went into developing
this model structure.
This model combines
traditional linear learning
with deep learning,
and so we can
feed in our categorical data
directly to the linear half
and then configure a DNN
with two dense layers
for the numerical data.
We can then train the
wide and deep model
just as we did with
our other model.
Notice here that
the caned estimator
expects the input function
rather than data set directly.
Estimators control their
own sessions and graphs
so that at the time of
distribution they can build
and replicate
graphs as necessary.
So our input function
here gives the estimate
of the instructions for
getting our data set
and producing the
tensors that we want,
and the estimates will then call
this function in its own graph
and session when necessary.
Here we wrap the same
data loading function
that we used in our
previous model in a lambda
with the correct file
names preconfigured
so that the estimator can
call this function at runtime
to get the appropriate
features and labels.
We can use the same strategy
to evaluate using test data.
And lo and behold, if we
run this for 20 epochs,
we have another train model that
we can compare to the first.
Note that this is just one of
a number of canned estimates
that TensorFlow offers.
We have boost to trees, model
for time series analysis, r
and n's, walls,
and more as well.
Note that for
estimators, we first
have to tell the model what
shape and type of tensor
to expect at inference time.
For that, we have to define
an input receiver function.
It sounds confusing.
And I'm not going to lie.
It's a little confusing.
We want a function that
builds the tensor shapes
that we expect at serving time.
Luckily, we can use this
convenience function,
which just needs the
shapes of the tensors we
will want to run inference on.
Because we are in
eager mode, we can just
grab a row from our
data set and use
that to tell the convenience
function what to expect.
Here we grab the features
from the first row
and don't do any
additional processing
because we are assuming at
inference time the data will
look the same, just
without labels.
In real world scenarios,
your inference data
may need additional
processing, such as parsing
from a live request string.
And the input receiver
function is where
you would encode that logic.
We can then use the
function returned
by build raw serving input
receiver function to generate
a saved model that can
be used in TF serving, TF
hub, and elsewhere just
as we did with keras.
So now we've made a full loop.
And if we had more time,
we could keep going
and try out some
more of these paths.
I'll leave you to
explore that, and I
hope that this series
has been as fun for you
as it was for me.
Remember if you
have any questions,
please leave them in
the comments below
and don't forget to hit
that subscribe button.